What exactly did it take for Heath Ledger to pull
off his Oscar-winning Joker performance? Does the
diary he kept at the time hold any clues about
his tragic death? Keep watching for the answers.
Over a decade after it first appeared on the
big screen, Heath Ledger's rendition of the
Joker in 2008's "The Dark Knight" stands
above all other supervillain portrayals.
He came across as cold, thoughtful, and scarily
real, bringing the Clown Prince of Crime
to life in a new and impactful way. Pulling off
such a chilling performance didn't come easy,
and was the result of impressive dedication
on the part of the man behind the makeup.
Heath Ledger took his acting work incredibly
seriously and didn't shy away from an
opportunity to push himself as an artist.
He'd envelop himself in his characters to
ensure he got every mannerism, line, and facial
expression just right, no matter the nature of
the project. Director Christopher Nolan's vision
of Joker was no exception, and as it turns out,
Ledger took his methodology to the next
level for the part with a disturbing diary.
While much of the diary's content – playing
cards, comic panels, and various quotes
from "The Dark Knight" – centers on the
Joker, it also contains many extra images
and writings. These give fans a glimpse
into Ledger's mind as he delved deeper
down the rabbit hole. The small book has become
almost as legendary as the character itself,
leading fans and critics to praise Ledger for his
unsettling commitment to his craft. Because of
the foreboding nature of its content, however,
it comes with its fair share of urban legends.
To truly become the Joker, Heath Ledger chose
to isolate himself from the rest of the world
for months at a time, locking himself in his
apartment or hotel room to iron out the finer
details of the character. During his exile,
he'd work on his diary free of distraction.
He documented his thought process, important
quirks to the character, and other notes that
describe how he came up with so many now-iconic
parts of the Joker's characterization.
In a German documentary about the late actor,
titled Too Young to Die: Heath Ledger, his father,
Kim Ledger, was interviewed on the unorthodox
nature of his son's preparation. While the elder
Ledger admitted that the isolation and prolonged
study was nothing new for his son, he described
the Joker journal as being on a whole new level.
Even as bizarre as its content seemed on its own,
the two strategies Ledger utilized in tandem were
undeniably crucial to perfecting his performance.
The diary is full of clippings from comic
books, which Ledger read in isolation.
Pages of the diary are filled with handwritten
versions of the Joker's dialogue from his scenes,
including the infamous moment when the
Joker detonates a bomb in a Gotham City
hospital. In the documentary, Kim
mentions that when they were kids,
Ledger's older sister Kate would dress him
in a nurse's uniform, like he wears in the
movie. When Ledger described his version of
the character to Empire in 2007, he said,
"I ended up landing more in the realm of a
psychopath. Someone with very little to no
conscience towards his acts. He's just an absolute
sociopath, a cold-blooded, mass-murdering clown.”
“Ah-ah-ah. Let’s not blow this out of proportion.”
Ledger also told Empire about Christopher
Nolan's input on the character. Ledger said,
"Chris has given me free rein. Which is
fun, because there are no real boundaries
to what The Joker would say or do. Nothing
intimidates him, and everything is a big joke."
On set, Ledger often improvised
moments during scenes, and
Ledger rarely told Christopher Nolan
exactly what he was planning to do.
The unpredictability made directing his scenes
much more intense than usual. One of the most
memorable moments in the film that Ledger
improvised takes place during the scene when
Jim Gordon, played by Gary Oldman, gets promoted
to police commissioner shortly after capturing
the Joker. The Joker, in a nearby prison cell,
sarcastically claps along with everyone else.
Among the many seemingly random images and
frantic scribblings inside Ledger's diary were
a handful of references to Stanley Kubrick's 1971
classic "A Clockwork Orange." More specifically,
there were a few images of fictional psychopath
Alex DeLarge. The main character of the piece,
he's best described as a sadistic teenager
who commits heinous crimes and terrorizes
anyone and everyone he encounters simply for the
fun of it. Is that description ringing any bells?
Another one of the most important things to get
right when developing a new Joker adaptation
is the character's laugh. Every actor that has
stepped into that role put a different spin on
it that fit that specific incarnation perfectly.
Ledger knew he couldn't simply copy Mark Hamill or
Jack Nicholson, as that would cheapen the
character, so he had to do some digging and create
his own laugh from scratch. As his diary detailed,
he found his muse in the form of a hyena.
The hyena is synonymous with its
"laugh," a call the species uses
to express any number of emotions. The
sound is generally high-pitched and
comes out as a threatening cackle that's
perfect for the Clown Prince of Crime.
[Joker laughing]
In Ledger's journal, there was at least
one picture of a laughing hyena included,
most likely citing his interest in using their
"laugh" as a starting point for his own. Looking
back on his performance, the similarities between
the two vocal expressions are rather striking.
On January 22, 2008, Heath Ledger
tragically passed away at the young
age of 28 due to cardiac arrest. According
to the medical examiner, his passing came
as a result of an overdose of prescription
medication that brought on a heart attack.
It was no secret that Ledger went to
serious extremes to slip into character,
but did it contribute to his untimely death? After
all, the last entry did say, quote, "BYE BYE."
So, was there any validity to the claims
that Joker pushed Ledger over the edge?
Simply put, despite his journal's cryptic nature
and his devotion to the Joker role, Ledger's
death wasn't a direct cause of his preparation.
His drug abuse issues weren't a new phenomenon,
and his debut in the DC universe wasn't driving
him into any kind of depression. His sister,
Kate Ledger, set the record straight on
her brother's attitude towards the role,
telling reporters at the
2017 Tribeca Film Festival,
"He wasn't depressed about the Joker."
His Joker diary was very concerning out of
context, but it turned out to be nothing
more than a tool by which Ledger was able
to pull off the performance of a lifetime.
If you or someone you know is struggling with
addiction, please call the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Administration's 24/7 National
Helpline at 1-800-662-HELP. That's 1-800-662-4357.